du éducation toujours l'académie de
versailles a célébré pendant deux jours
les 30 ans de l'instauration du
baccalauréat professionnel le premier
diplôme de formation en alternance école
entreprise pour fêter cet anniversaire
les étudiants ont investi le palais des
congrès de versailles mercredi et jeudi
lors d'un forum une vingtaine de stands
tenus par les élèves et leurs
professeurs étaient installés pour
promouvoir les différentes filières
présentes dans l'académie comme la
coiffure la vente ou encore les
guérisseurs
j'ai beaucoup entendu de mal sur le bac
professionnel mais j'ai toujours fait la
part des choses pour moi j'avais envie
d'être un professionnel
j'ai toujours défendu le professionnel
est pour moi après chacun son avis mais
on va que professionnel on peut plus
atteindre le monde du travail
alors qu'en bac général c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué je pense que l'image des
bacs pro a bien évolué du côté de
des lycées du côté des entreprises mais
passer du côté du public et des familles
il faut que les familles sachent que
faire un bac professionnel
c'est une formation de très grande
qualité qui permet l'emploi et qui
permet la poursuite d'études
il faut en faire la promotion c'est un
très très bel objet